I want you to stay with me doing the
prayer join you and Isaiah as far as
that as long as that beam weren't your
brother I'm gonna take care that take
care it yeah what you gonna do you hurt
no Killa Oh cuz actually answer to
everything right that's who you are
today it was two people we know but
everyday it's at least to [ __ ] her
cousin you do otherwise
come bhai and I grew up here too we
gonna have to make choices in life to
heal it's hurting you chose the latter
my purchase one day you dimitri destroy
this community 364 days a year
and if your faith will be putting all
this hitting the streets you're hoping
that we'd off each other we didn't and
now they stoking the fire in another
[ __ ] way our neighborhood is
under siege gentlemen from a government
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of us
there's a lot of good people out there
who we gonna have to protect now see the
end of her face forgot about one thing
they forgot about us this is our home
so let's show these [ __ ] never
to [ __ ] with our island again a skull
you're angry yes I'm angry very angry
you want to release that anger I need to
thank you for your honest answer so
first a few formalities but easiest the
official flower of the experiment they
represent rebirth in the Box you have
recording lenses contacts should you
choose to actively participate wear them
on the evening and they'll document
everything you do as I said greater
participation yields greater financial
compensation next will implant a
tracking device after that you'll be all
set as they say to purge announcing the
commencement of the first purge tonight
allows people a release from all the
hatred and violence that they keep up
inside the booth this won't bring him
back
it won't make you feel any better thank
you
it is a night that is defining our
country
citizens this will be a tradition we
celebrate every year join the first
purge how do you think says always see
you tonight
people are now calling this
controversial experiment of legalized
crime the purge you and Isaiah just stay
with me doing approach oh we're gonna be
fine on how we are here with dr. may up
Dale
she came up with this experiment is the
purge a political device it is a
psychological one if we want to save our
country we must release all our anger in
one night tonight we'll see the good and
evil and everyone this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the first purge our
neighborhood is under siege from a
government who doesn't give a [ __ ] about
any of us at the siren of crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours there's a lot of good people out
there who we're gonna have to protect
you all emergency services will be
suspended we gotta be prepared for
anything your government thanks you for
your participation parties you predicted
a much higher level of participation
human nature does not obey the laws of
politics what the hell is going on
they all ex-military some funky going
down D you're saving soldiers into the
island disguised as citizens this
country needs for this dork no one's
coming to help us
after tonight nothing will ever be the
same again they forgot about one thing
they forgot about us what have I done
a strong
just remember all the good the purge
does
you